as you guys know we are building out our
home studios so we are in a makeshift
studio at the moment we are going to be
doing a Google hangout for the first
time normally we do remote we do skypes
but our skype portion of the studio and
our main studio is all being built out
should be good to go in a couple weeks
but I did not want to start you find
people of content especially these crazy
times that we live in so this week I'm
very excited to be talking to Jordan
Peterson he is a University of Toronto
psychology professor he has really been
in the thick of this free speech thing
and pretty much I would say about 700 of
you roughly requested for him to be on
the show and for us to sit down I've
read a lot about him lately
and Jordan welcome to the show welcome
to the group and report thanks very much
so thank you for being our Google
hangout guinea pig and bearing with us
as we are in between studios this is a
pure free speech zone that probably
makes the guy like you feel pretty good
yeah well you know good that means we
might really discuss some things that
are important instead of pussyfooting
around
absolutely so let's get right to it so
for people that don't know your story
what has sort of put you in the news
over the last couple of months it's
actually quite astounding because you
are in Canada which is a place that has
a strong tradition of free speech so for
people that have no idea what's going on
with you can you just lay out the basics
of what's transpired over the last
couple months yeah well there's a
there's some new legislation that's
pending at the federal level called bill
c16 and bill c16 adds gender identity
and gender expression to the list of
protected categories under the Canadian
Human Rights Code Canadian Human Rights
Act and also adds transgressions against
those categories people who are in those
categories to the hate speech provisions
of the Criminal Code so it's it's very
very punitive legislation and that in
itself is is is somewhat appalling
although it's not obvious why but
there's a similar legislation already in
many provinces in
Canada which equivalent to the state
level and B there's a requirement that
that originated in Ontario for people to
use preferred what they're what are
called preferred pronouns to address
someone and as far as I can tell by
reading over the legislation failure to
use someone's preferred pronouns is now
a hate crime in Canada right so let's
let's just pause there for a second all
right that wasn't really understand what
that means that means that if you
potentially accidentally refer to
someone as the wrong pronoun you may not
realize if someone happens to be a male
or a female you could potentially be in
legal trouble now that also you could do
it intentionally which I think under
free speech would be fine as well but
even accidentally we're going down a
pretty slippery slope in the legislation
like there there are legal moves afoot
in many organizations at a policy level
or a legal level to also alter the way
that the law is interpreted so that
instead of judging someone on the intent
of their speech you judge them on the
consequences of their speech and also um
- - and this is particularly to say with
sexual harassment policies to remove and
this is happening mostly at universities
right now although it'll happen another
organization soon enough to remove if
you're accused of sexual harassment or
worse instead of you presumed innocent
until proven guilty they use the
doctrine of preponderance of evidence
and so so not only are there changes
afoot to to regulate the way that people
speak they call that compelled speech
the American Supreme Court ruled on that
one point and ruled it unconstitutional
that it contradicted the First Amendment
that compelled speech so but in Canada I
think these pieces of legislation are
also unconstitutional but of course no
one's yet challenged them as far as you
have to challenge them to prove that
which would be all the way to the
Supreme Court
yeah okay so we're obviously going to
focus mostly on the free speech
component of it I would I would imagine
that there's probably a few people
listening to this that would say wait a
minute
maybe this guy just doesn't like
transgender people maybe he just wants
to be offensive to transgender people so
I'll just kick that back to you is that
the case at all well a lot of the people
who've been pushing this legislation
claim to be speaking for the
transgendered community but that's not
self-evident to me at all I've received
many letters of support from
transgendered people and actually just
in a conversation with a transgendered
woman in Vancouver
most transgendered people especially the
classic type I would say speaking
psychologically are people have had a
difficult time adjusting to their
biological sex identity since they were
young and some of them undergo fairly
radical transformations in an attempt to
become the other sex and they have no
problem with pronouns they just want to
be the other one mm-hmm
yeah that's right so they don't have any
caught problem with he or she in fact
they undergo a tremendous amount of
trouble I would say to transform
themselves for better or worse into a
member of the opposite sex the people
who are pushing this legislation forward
claim to speak for the transgendered
community but you can claim to speak for
any community you want that doesn't make
you a legitimate representative right so
so that's a great point and actually the
the girl that you spoke to up in
Vancouver we've had on our Rubin report
fan show so people can check that out
her name is Darren Meyer I think she's
an excellent spokesperson for the trans
community
I don't know that she's asking to be a
spokesman for the trans community but
sometimes people are sort of just thrust
into things so okay so in and of itself
you have no problem with trans people
right is that fair to say well I don't I
don't I don't have any problem with
trans people um I mean I'm a clinical
psychologist I've dealt with every
variety of person you could possibly
imagine and a fair number of people that
you couldn't possibly imagine and I'm so
I'm quite comfortable with people who
don't fit normally into normal
categories and I know how to deal with
people who are in that situation very
well so the idea that I'm doing this
because I'm somehow made nervous by
people who don't fit neatly into gender
categories is which
actually the sort of trip that you'd
expect people on the radical left pull
because it's what they do all the time
they called me a racist
too because the University of Toronto
human resources and equity department is
been taking advice from a group called
the black liberation collective which
was formulated by two women one is who
one who is a self-avowed black
supremacist who believes that white
people are inferior because they don't
have enough melanin melanin in their
skin and that makes them unable to
receive cosmic energy and transforming
or for thought and in fact that one my
problem is that is definitely your
problem and the other one is under
investigation for embezzling three
hundred thousand dollars from the
University of Toronto Students Union and
so and they also will not disavow
violence in their pursuit of social
transformation the University of Toronto
HR an equity departments taking policy
advice from them which i think is
appalling and because I've objected to
that I'm being tarred with the epithet
of racist so but it's a cycle it's it's
typical of this kind of mob behavior
that the PC authoritarians like to
engage in whenever anybody ruffles their
feathers yeah I'm curious were you
keenly aware of that authoritarianism
before you were subjected to it I mean I
suspect that the academic level you've
seen a lot of this building and I've
seen some of your subsequent tweets over
the last couple months that you sort of
had an idea about this but did you
really know exactly how bad it was until
you were the target of their aim I
probably knew uhm I mean I've been
disturbed about political correctness
for a very long time I've studied the
development of totalitarian and
authoritarian systems for about four
decades and I've been keeping a close
eye on political correctness since the
early 1990s because if it's spiked when
I used to teach at Harvard I talked
there from 93 to 98 it's fight there was
quite a spike in political correctness
in the early part of the 1990s but it
kind of settled down and so I thought it
had gone back underground to where it
was spawned but it made its comeback
quite dramatically in the last five
years and I've seen a lot of very
ominous things occurring a lot of them
on American campuses I mean the episode
at Yale
the Halloween costumes for example in
the fact that one of the people faculty
members involved in that actually
resigned was was one of the more
egregious examples but certainly not the
only one so I made a couple of YouTube
videos complaining about the bill c16
and also about the University of
Toronto's decision to make anti racism
and antibodies training so-called
mandatory for its staff which I thought
was an appalling invasion of of their
employees political freedom and still do
believe that and also know that
mandatory anti racism an anti bias
training has no it's not validated as a
procedure an educational or
psychological procedure to reduce racism
and bias the evidence in fact suggests
that it has the opposite effect and then
I also found that the University of
Toronto I got their training material
once they started their mandatory
training programs and they're actually
pushing they define equity it's a
charred equity Human Resources inequity
and this is coming your way just so
everyone knows it the question is what
is equity because that's a different
word than equality
well they defined equity in their
training material it's equality of
outcome now you're going to think right
this is one he regular stuff right it's
unbelievably dangerous and it's so
pernicious because here's the hypothesis
imagine you have an organizational
pyramid right and there's layers of
power and then each layer of power has a
demographic it's you know it has a
demographic element right I mean there
are men and women and people of
different races and so forth so you can
segregate and analyze each strata by its
demography well the hypothesis is you do
that then you compare it to the general
population and if there isn't a
one-to-one match then the organization
is oppressive and corrupt and needs to
be retooled and this is what the
University of Toronto administration is
forcing its staff to learn okay okay so
that when people feel this when people
say they and it sounds a deserter the
two of us working towards that equality
of outcome with anything you have you
can you just have to you just have to
force things a hell of a lot harder than
anyone wants to foresee right so I guess
I guess technically you can force it but
I think maybe I meant
morally or ethically or how about that
well what happens is everybody ends up
sitting in the rubble and they're all
equal in outcome so and everyone's equal
and um cometh enough people are dead
Phil oh and I mean no sound like
dramatic phrases but I know exactly what
he quality of outcome Theory did to
places like the Soviet Union and to
Maoist China it was absolutely
I was absolutely and unbelievably
disastrous and murderous so I can't
believe that because she was always out
there can you explain how we get there
how'd you get there from the academic
level that we're dealing with it too you
know regimes like that well you get
there you get there when when see people
think these are academic issues but what
they fail to realize is that what
happens on University campuses happens
everywhere five years later mm-hmm the
people who run things are trained in
universities and so however they're
trained that's how things are going to
be run um
equality of outcome equality of outcome
means that force has to be applied to
make sure that every institution at
every level falls into compliance with
thee with the Equality doctrine and you
do that by retooling organizations and
putting quotas on people for example or
firing people or whatever you have to do
so for example 65% of the medical
faculty at the University of Toronto was
women who's going to equality of outcome
doctrine well what do you do you fire 15
you fire 15 percent and replace them
with men well I mean in engineering of
course the preponderance of people are
male but but the pernicious idea is that
that's a marker of oppression and
equality of outcome well it's it's the
it's a fundamental it's it's worse than
a Marxist doctrine it's the most
pernicious of Marxist doctrines we
thought a whole Cold War against that we
damn near put the whole world to the
torch to ensure that that philosophy
didn't spread and in Alberta another
Canadian province the Alberta Teachers
Association recently launched their LBGT
I can't forget that rights LGBT thank
you thank you
education material and there
to teach kids from grade 7 grade 12 that
there's no relationship between biology
and gender which is also written into
this legislation by the way and I want
to come back to that because that's a
lot more important that people think
they seriously proposed and children
address each other as comrade so how
much of this then is just a flaw in the
West that our academic systems have sort
of rotted which then leads up to our
leaders rotting and that no one is
really fighting for the very principle
that as you said we've fought Wars over
I mean millions of people have died over
free expression and free ideas and
battling back some of this marks this
stuff and it seems to me that it's only
now at the beginnings with stuff that
you're doing at a few other people where
it's starting to people are realizing
that actually free expression free
speech free thought and a quality of
opportunity not of outcome these are
actually cool ideas but it seems like
right now we're on the losing end of
this stuff well I would it looks to me
like we are I mean I try to do some so
to get some sense of how this works I
would recommend that your readers go
online and look up 12 websites look up
women who studies websites I don't care
where you look them up because they're
all the same and there's and I think
that the women in gender studies types
the the ethnicity studies the racial
studies all that what I consider the
disciplines that are there civil
disciplines their their their peripheral
disciplines they should have never been
incorporated into the university um they
tell you exactly what they're up to they
they believe that the West is a
patriarchy first of all which is a word
that's become so accepted now that
people look at me and surprised when I
object to its use you know it's big it's
become so much part of the parlance well
of course it's a patriarchy it's like
it's not so obvious that it's a
patriarchy and besides that the idea
that it's not only a patriarchy but it's
a corrupt patriarchy at every level
including the level of fundamental
categorization and that it needs to be
retooled from the bottom up and that
what we do in our Women's Studies
programs is we train people in that
doctrine and we teach them how to be put
political activists and and infiltrating
agents and I'm not making this up all
you have to
do is go on to the websites and read it
it's laid out there for everyone to see
and the very idea that the West is a
corrupt patriarchy is well about
that'sthat's three to old Marxism mixed
with a bit of post-modernism you know
the most modernist especially Jacques
Derrida who I think is is corrupt and
dangerous beyond beyond comprehension
virtually driven by resentment virtually
nothing else but very very smart and
very very treacherous he basically
claimed that the only reason that human
beings categorized to begin with is to
exclude and the thing is is that it's
very difficult doctrine to to think
through because categories exclude
mm-hmm but and they can be misused for
purposes of exclusion which is what
unfair discrimination constitutes and
it's unfair when you deny someone
position that they're competent to
occupy for reasons that have nothing to
do with with the issues at hand right
that's that's that's the kind of
discrimination that people should be
objecting to but the idea that
categorization itself the purpose of
categorization is to exclude in a
discriminatory fashion it's an assault
it's truly an assault on reason itself
because we categorize we're not that
bright human beings and and there's lots
of world out there and so we categorize
the world to simplify it so that we can
so that we can act in it properly and to
equate that with to equate the very act
of categorization with discrimination is
well that's what the post modernist have
done right it's actually it strikes me
as incredibly dangerous we categorize
because you Tate you make value
judgments on people's behavior their
thoughts all of those things and then we
categorize them as good bad or
indifferent or whatever it may be better
scholar were scholars smarter Dumber
better athlete whatever it is if you
didn't do that then that sort of
postmodern thinking we'd all just be one
amorphous blob but I guess that that's
sort of how they want us right yeah well
I think it isn't I think it is an
assault on the idea of value judgment
per se because that's become a
pejorative that's a value judgment it's
like you
yeah I mean value judgments value
judgments are what provide life with
meaning in ethically speaking because
your life has meaning when you're moving
from a place that's not so good to a
place that's better that's what
motivates you without value judgments
without the distinction between are now
or between between between bad and
better or bad and good
there's no impetus to move forward
there's no motivation there's no there's
no significance in life right now you
believe that there's an assault on that
because the problem with having
significance in your life is that
requires responsibility and one thing
the SJW types the pc authoritarians
don't want is any responsibility for
anything whatsoever yet so you would say
that you should judge that's actually
your right and your duty is persecute
you should not prejudge correct actually
should not be prejudiced or speciously
like that if i'm trying to hire someone
to compose a piece of music to me
whether they're whether they're female
or male or black or white or or what
sexual orientation they have for that
matter is irrelevant to the production
of the the outcome and so you shouldn't
do it because it's counterproductive
it's not even in your interests to do it
much less not in the interests of the
person that you're being prejudiced
against so how do we how do we untangle
some of this stuff for all of the
well-intentioned sjw's that i talk about
all the time that you talk about all the
time for all of the people that are
enamored with the safe spaces and
trigger warnings and that think that
they're doing good because i don't mind
that i don't believe that i don't
believe the good intention idea really
well because like many many terrible
things have been done in history in the
name of good intention so why should i
assume that just because someone states
they have good intentions that their
intentions are actually good no they
that that's predicated on the idea that
people are intrinsically good and i
don't buy that for a second people are
intrinsically good and evil and and and
and you cannot take someone's intentions
especially their political attentions
especially if they have to do with with
changing others you can't take that at
face value
I think that you can understand the
politically correct types very well if
you substitute resentment every for the
word compassion every time they use
compassion you substitute resentment and
you've got a pretty good sense of
exactly what they're up to and the idea
that you're doing people a favor by
making them safe isn't it's it's it's
the proposition that Sigmund Freud spent
his whole life fighting against because
the classic oedipal mother who devours
her children like the witch in Hansel
and Gretel fat you know feeds them
nothing but candy and fountains them up
so she can eat them that's that's a
cautionary tale for our time I'll tell
you is those people say well you know I
did it with the best intentions all I
was trying to do is protect my children
so children aren't there to protect
children are there to encourage and
toughen and and so the idea that these
that this is good intentions no way man
I don't buy it for a second yeah good
intentions yeah I guess I would I would
give a little caveat to what I said
which is that I think for the most part
the young people that are getting
indoctrinated with this stuff when they
hear about it I think there are their
intentions are to do good I think the
leaders of a lot of these movements and
the higher up higher up academics and
things like that they really understand
what's going on and realize realize that
is about power no yeah I was the young
people either and the reason for that is
like Carl Jung talked about the unholy
alliance that a kneadable mother formed
with her child so if your mother is very
very hyper dependent there's two things
you can do about it you can rebel
against it or you can take the offering
and the advantage to taking the offering
that the Alliance is basically um you
never leave and I'll never require that
you do anything right that's the
dependent that's the mother with the
hyper dependent child okay so how do you
translate that into a political agenda
it's easy I'm going to teach you a
political ideology and it will put you
in a position of moral superiority and
it will require absolutely no
responsibility whatsoever on your part
and you'll be able to demonize and
victimize people and have a place where
you can vent your resentment and spleen
and so that's what's happening with the
young people
and I mean I don't want to make it I
don't want to be over categorical about
it I know that people get confused but
but I don't think that there's any
excuse for it and I think that there's a
corruption in the idea that what I
should do as a political agent is change
you or even change the world it's like
if you want to take and you want to say
against the corruption of the world then
you should start by fighting against the
corruption in your own heart and that's
a real battle and that really requires
responsibility you should discipline
yourself you should get rid of your fear
you should expand your skills you should
stop being an uncarved block and then
and you should stop being pathetic you
should start being attractive to people
of the opposite sex you should sharpen
yourself up and you should be have
enough humility to know bloody well that
when you're 18 years old you don't know
enough about the world to go out
radically reshape it so they're being
sold a bill of goods there's no doubt
about it but the reason that it's so
pernicious is because it appeals to the
most to the most hypocritical and
deceitful and responsibility shedding
element of young people and of course
it's hard for young people to discipline
themselves and it's a long way up back
into the middle class you know so
there's a real struggle that requires
responsibility and encouraged to place
yourself in the world as a productive
citizen to hell of a lot easier just to
abandon that end and complain about the
entire structure of society yeah it's
interesting I didn't think we were going
to go exactly in this direction with
this but you're really giving the best
argument for liberty and for
individualism over collectivism right
yeah yeah well this is its this is
intimate this is absolutely
individualism versus collectivism and
you know I was interviewed by a young
journalist today from Carleton
University and you know she she asked me
straight out about my white privilege
and I thought there's a question I find
unbelievably I find it appalling it's an
appalling question she has she's a
second-year political science dude she
had no idea about the history of the
Soviet Union I asked her how many people
were killed in internal repression in
the Soviet Union and you know she had no
idea she had absolutely no idea she
guessed a million people which meant
meant she was out by a factor of about
50 right and she had never heard
the of the problem with the idea of
collective group based guilt no and one
of the one of the one of the processes
by which the Marxist doctrine was
transformed into the murderous outcomes
in the Soviet Union was to play
collective guilt games
the Soviets killed all their um
productive farmers in the late 1920s
because they regarded them anybody who
owned a house these were people who were
serfs like 30 years before some of them
had like clambered up the peasant ranks
so that they may be owned a brick house
and could employ one person and had a
cow and some you know an end and a field
or two but they were they were producing
almost all of Russia's agricultural
output and it's because a small minority
of people also always produce the
majority of whatever's being produced so
they threw them all on trains shipped
them up to Siberia killed them all
collectivise the farms and in the
nineteen thirty six million Ukrainians
starve to death so this idea of
collective guilt and then the fact that
someone can come right out and you know
question me on my white privilege if if
that isn't racism I've never encountered
racism in my life
you